hey everyone i am rebecca khandelwal and
i welcome you all to simply learns
youtube channel
in this session we will discuss longest
common substring
we shall begin our session by discussing
the problem statement
then we will discuss the algorithmic
solution to find the longest common
substring
finally we will implement the set
function to find the longest common
substring
in the code editor but before we begin
make sure you have subscribed to our
youtube channel and clicked on the bell
icon below so you never miss an update
from simply runs youtube channel
so without any further ado let's get
started with the problem statement
the longest common substring problem
involves finding the length of the
longest string that is the substring of
two or more strings there might be a
number of solution to a situation now
let's discuss the algorithmic solution
to find the longest common substring
first we must determine the length of
the longest common suffix for each
substring
of both strings and save it in the
database
now if the last characters in the
longest common suffix match
their length will be reduced by one or
if the last characters in the longest
common suffix do not match then the
result will be zero
now we will look at the suffix of
distinct substrings that ends at
different indices finally we will
conclude that longest common substring
is the longest common suffix with the
maximum length
we have now discussed the problem
statement and the algorithmic solution
to find the longest common substring
now let's implement this solution in the
code editor we will start with a
function that will return the length of
the longest common substring
of a string x and y
and
lc
sub
str
its argument as
star care
x
comma
character pointer
why
comma
and
the size of the first
string x
comma
end
and this will be the size of the
another string wire
now we will create a table to store the
length of longest common suffixes of
string
now we will create a array lc surf to
store the length of the longest common
surface
so
end
lc serve
at
m plus one
and n
plus one
and another variable
result
equals to zero
this will be used to store the length of
the longest common substring
now
we will follow the steps to build the lc
suffix in the bottom of fashion
so for
and i equals to 0
i less than
equals to m
i plus plus
another nested loop 4
and
j is equals to 0
j less than equals to
and
j plus plus
now the first row in the first column
entries will have no logical meaning
they will be used only for the
simplicity of the program
so if
i is equals to
zero or
j
is equals to
0
then
lcs
at i comma j
will be equals to zero
else
is
x
at i minus 1
is equals to
y
at j minus 1.
then
lc surf
at i
j
will be equals to
lc surf
at i minus 1
and j minus 1
plus
1.
and
the result
will be equals to
the maximum
of
result
comma
lc surf
at i
comma j
else
lc surf
at i comma j
will be equals to zero
and we will return
result
now let's write the main block
we will have
string care
x
is equals to
calm
down
and
another string
car
y
is equals to
keep
calm
now we will store the length
n
m equals to
str alien
of x
and
n
will have
strln
of y
now
we will print
the length
of
longest
common
substring
lcs
str
at x comma y comma m comma n
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we are getting the length
of the longest common substring s4 which
was khan and this was all for today's
session hope you guys found it
informative and helpful
if you liked this session then like
share and subscribe
if you have any question then you can
drop them in the comment section below
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more from simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here